[MOOING]
MALCOLM HAYES: I'm Malcolm Hayes.
I'm a dairy farmer from Cookernup in Western Australia.
The property here, our home property or what we call our dairy platform,
is about 240 hectares.
Presently, we're milking about 360 cows in the dairy,
producing about three and a half million liters of milk a year.
Last year about this time, after a lot of searching around
for a better system, we decided to go with a GEA cow management system
where we installed milk monitors and automatic ID systems on our cows,
which it's actually reducing the labor that we need to use in the dairy.
And we're actually managing the cows a lot better than we did before.
With the better management, we're certainly getting our cows in calf
better, as we have a system to identify cows which are on heat.
[MOO]
All of the cows have a responder on, them
which is a thing which has a motion sensor in it and a transponder in it
to actually register the, so the computer
can read the cow's number as the cow comes in the dairy.
This is how we know what goes on individually with each cow.
If a cow gets sick and milk drops off, alarms will come up in the dairy.
And we'll know straight away.
If she stops eating because there's no motion or lack of motion in the cow,
we'll know straight away.
It even has an app that goes to my phone that I
can look up the cows when I'm away.